Liaison, it's a post-Brexit spy series
Mixed with an impossible love story
and lots of action.
When I first started working on this,
you kind of had to figure out
how to ground it,
how to make you really believe
you were right inside the action.
When I read the script
and I started to look at the scale of
what was proposed, I thought,
“Oh, this is happening on television”?
We're talking about a flood
and an airplane almost crashing.
I'm thinking
“You're going to do this stuff”?
I think the one we can imagine
the most clearly is
they hack into the train system.
We've lost all control of the signals.
And not only did
we have to plan the crash itself,
we had to also plan and
shoot a huge aftermath scene.
We took real
trains and we cut them up into pieces.
And we've made this completely authentic.
We have hundreds of extras here today
with Eva Green in the middle
amongst all this chaos.
You know, I was expecting
to shoot that scene against green screen.
So when I arrived on set, I was like,
“Oh my God, this is amazing”.
The train had been derailed.
Lots of smoke everywhere.
All the extras were like wounded passengers.
It was very impressive.
3, 2 ,1, action!
Vincent Cassel is very intense on screen.
There's something very rugged,
very animal about him
that suits the character of Gabriel
beautifully.
I'm not a big guy.
So how do you do it
when the guy's twice your size
and you have to do what you got to do?
Yeah, exactly.
You go straight to the point.
Don't move!
Liaison is a forward moving thriller
with a dangerous love story.
It's a challenge,
but it's really exciting.
It's extremely ambitious.
It looks good.
It's believable.
It's amazing.